♪ ♪
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN STICKING A
KNIFE IN THE BACK BORDER PATROL.
IN THE INTEREST OF PREPARING
DISCIPLINE MULTIPLE HORSE BACK
MOUNTED AGENTS CONNECTED WITH
THE INFAMOUS WHIPPING HOAX WHICH
BORDER PATROL AGENTS ACCUSED OF
HITTING HAITIAN MIGRANTS AT THE
TEXAS BORDER LAST SEPTEMBER
TURNS OUT THOSE WERE JUST HORSE
RANCH AND THOSE AGENTS WERE
CLEARED OF CRIMINAL WRONGDOING
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T DO ANYTHING
WRONG.
BUT NOW BIDEN IS GOING AFTER
THEM FOR ADMINISTRATIVE
VIOLATIONS.
IT'S NOT A SURPRISE AFTER HOW
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE MEDIA
POSTAL HE HIS GUYS, REMEMBER?
>> IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
I PROMISE YOU PEOPLE WILL PAY.
WE UNDERSTAND AND AGREE THIS IS
BEEN AN INCREDIBLY
HEART-WRENCHING ISSUE.
>> THOSE DISTURBING IMAGES OF.
>> I WAS OUTRAGED BY IT, IT WAS
HORRIBLE.
AND DEEPLY TROUBLING.
>> BORDER PATROL AGENTS ARE
FUMING, WITH ONE THING TO FOX
THE SO-CALLED PUNISHMENT IS B.S.
WHATEVER THAT MEANS.
JO ANN, LOOK, THEY DON'T BELIEVE
IN DUE PROCESS, DO THEY?
>> I FIND THAT IN THE LONG LIST
OF EMBARRASSING THINGS FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION COME OF THIS TO
ME GOES TO THE TOP.
IT INCORPORATES ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT ARE WRONG.
THEY'VE NEVER BEEN OUTSIDE OF
THE EASTERN SEABOARD SO THEY
DON'T KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
ACTUALLY RIDE A HORSE AND
UTILIZE A HORSE.
THEY'VE CONVICTED THESE GUYS
BEFORE THEY EVEN INVESTIGATED.
THEN WHEN THEY FOUND OUT -- IT
WAS HORSE RACING AND THEY DIDN'T
DO ANYTHING WRONG?
THEY STILL THAN POLITIFACT.
THEY DON'T DESERVE ANYTHING BUT
AN APOLOGY.
ALL OF THESE AGENTS ON HORSEBACK
THAT THEY APPEAR THEY'VE BEEN ON
DESK DUTY SINCE LAST SEPTEMBER.
WERE DOWN 2,000 AGENTS OF THE
BORDER.
YOU THINK THAT'S A GOOD IDEA?
NOW TO ADD INSULT TO INJURY, TO
ADD ADMINISTRATIVE VIOLATIONS?
WHAT COULD THEY POSSIBLY BE?
THE PRESIDENT COULD USE HIS
DISCRETION HERE.
HE COULD CALL THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY AND SAY LET IT
GO.
LET THESE GUYS GET BACK TO WORK.
BUT INSTEAD THEY HAVE TO COME UP
WITH SOME TRUMPED UP CHARGES
LIKE SOME THIRD WORLD DICTATOR,
THAT MAKES ME FURIOUS.
>> IS PROBABLY AFRAID OF HIS
PACE, JUDGE, DON'T YOU THINK?
>> WHY WOULD THEY REMEMBER?
>> THEY WOULDN'T BID THIS IS ALL
A MEDIA HOAX TO BEGIN WITH.
>> IT'S ALL THEATER.
JOE BIDEN IS ABOUT THEATER.
IS ABOUT MAKING THINGS UP.
IT'S ABOUT THE LAST TWO MONTHS
HAVE BEEN ABOUT THE LIES.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
LOOK ISN'T IT THE JOB OF THESE
BORDER PATROL AGENTS TO PROTECT,
OR TO PREVENT IMMIGRANTS FROM
ENTERING?
I MEAN WHAT IS THEIR JOB?
IF YOU DON'T WANT THEM TO DO
THAT DON'T PUT THEM ON A HORSE
AND DON'T PUT THEM AT THE
BORDER.
BUT THE TRUTH IS THAT THEY ARE
AFRAID OF DOING THEIR JOB FOR
FEAR THAT THEY'RE GONNA BE A
NATIONAL TELEVISION, THEY'RE
GOING TO LOSE THEIR JOB, SO WHAT
THEY ARE DOING IS THEY'RE DOING
NOTHING.
THE MEXICAN CARTEL IS LAUGHING
AT US AND TRYING TO SEND FENTON
KNOW THEY KNOW THE BORDER AGENTS
ARE AFRAID TO EXERCISE ANY KIND
OF CONTROL.
THEY ARE TOO BUSY MONITORING THE
SEARCH TO EVEN LOOK FOR
FENTANYL.
IN THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT IT'S
JUST PART OF LETTING IN THE
WORLD INTO THE UNITED STATES.
ONE IS ENOUGH ENOUGH?
SO THEY'LL COME UP WITH SOME
KIND OF ADMINISTRATIVE NONSENSE
AND JUST --
>> BUT COULDN'T THEY SUE THE
PRESIDENT FOR DEFAMATION?
>> NO.
HE'S PROTECTED.
>> GERALDO, IF THESE BORDER
PATROL AGENTS HAD HOISTED THE
HAITIANS UNDER THE BACK OF THE
HORSE AND THEN GALLOPED THEM
INTO THE COUNTRY, JOE PROBABLY
WOULD'VE SEEN THAT AND PUT A
CONGRESSIONAL MEDAL OF HONOR --
>> Geraldo: NONSENSE.
FIRST OF ALL I DEFER TO DANA,
WHO IS VERY MEASURED IN HER
EMOTIONS AND WHEN SHE SAYS THIS
IS THE WORST THING SHE'D SEEN I
RESPECT THAT DEEPLY BECAUSE I
KNOW YOU DON'T --
>> Dana: IT'S REALLY BAD TOO.
>> Geraldo: BUT LET ME SAY,
FIRST ON TO SAY SOMETHING ABOUT
THE HAITIANS PAIR THE HAITIANS
GET THE SHORT END OF THE STICK
EVERY TIME NO MATTER WHAT WHEN
IT COMES TO IMMIGRATION.
THE GOVERNMENT IS DYSFUNCTIONAL
AND CORRUPT, SO THEY GO FROM THE
ISLAND OF HISPANIOLA, THEY GO TO
CUBA COME ON RICKETY BOATS, THEY
SOMEHOW GET INTO
CENTRAL AMERICA, OR TO
SOUTH AMERICA BY BOAT, THEN THEY
WALK.
ABOUT THE BORDERS THE MEDIA THE
DEMOCRATS COVERED.
NOT THE COYOTES, NOT THE
SEXUAL ASSAULT, NOT THE DRUG
TRAFFICKING, THEY ONLY CARED
ABOUT THE BORDER WHEN THEY FOUND
A SUITABLE VILLAIN.
THE SUITABLE VILLAIN WAS
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEN HE STABBED THEM IN THE
BACK.
CALL IT A MACHO COWBOY.
>> I STEPPED THEM IN THE BACK OF
MY STABBED TRUMP IN THE BACK,
WHO ELSE DID I STEP IN THE BACK?
WHAT IF THAT LITTLE HAITIAN KID
WAS YOUR KID?
>> ONE OF THE REASONS THEY WERE
TRYING TO PUSH BACK IN THERE
TRYING TO GET THAT GUY, HAD JUST
ON THE BAG.
AS THE INVESTIGATION.
THE PERSON YOU DEEPLY RESPECTED,
GERALDO SAID.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
>> Geraldo: THEY ALL DESERVE
COMPASSION.
>> Greg: OF CLINTON PU